away from the frenzied turmoil of
westminster and arriving into the
freezing maelstrom of ukraine
the prime minister may see international
diplomacy as a sort of welcome
distraction but his meeting with the
ukrainian president carried a profound
importance 100 000 russian soldiers on
the border the threat of war hanging in
the air
it goes without saying that a further
russian invasion
of ukraine
would be a political disaster a
humanitarian disaster
in my view would also be
for russia
for the world
a military disaster
as well
and if that felt bleak
then the ukrainian leader with an army
of more than 200 000 raised an even
starker specter
i openly say this would not be a war
between ukraine and russia this will be
a full-scale war in europe
britain has offered more aid to ukraine
and says russia must back down in recent
days ukraine's president has been
telling people to be calm and western
allies have emphasized the power of
economic sanctions the tone here felt
very different the message being sent to
president putin was that any invasion of
ukraine risks tipping this whole region
into a long complicated and very bloody
war
the russian leader was conducting his
own diplomacy today welcoming hungary's
victor orban and insisting that the
crisis was actually all the fault of
nato
as you know we have been promised by
nato that it will not advance its
infrastructure one inch further
eastwards
everybody knows that
today we see where nato is poland
romania the baltic states
they said one thing and did another
thing
as the people say they played us simply
lied
the military buildup continues on both
sides of the border
de-escalation has become a political
buzzword it's talked about a lot but
there's no sign of it happening
adam parsons sky news kiev